when I was in high school came when I
was nine I got molested by a guy with
Down syndrome don't laugh I'm not
laughing why'd you laugh I'm it's just
that it's such a curveball I know can I
just say something I'm gonna say it
again and if you smile okay all right
but his name yeah what's your nib again
chin chin all right give me a second
don't ya give me a second all right I
just wasn't ready for that lioness now
I'm gonna say it again and if and if you
smile I'm gonna leave okay all right
hold on we can't write notes my right
just hold on no cuz then you're gonna
laugh don't laugh don't laugh
get serious B's open it up here when I
was you ready don't cover your mouth up
either hey you can't cover your mouth
the thing is that I you know I'm telling
you something that's like us it's
vulnerable time expressing truth to you
I do yeah I get serious if you cover
your mouth I just feel like you're
laughing nope let's do it all right so
when I was nine I was brutally molested
by okay you can't say why because that's
a curveball good dog sister look at your
mouth does that it's not a curse a
brutally had some all right so I had
your tips there so when I was nine years
old every day for a summer in there yeah
all right let's try it again
don't get up I'm sorry how about this
how about I'm not gonna add more
information the information that I have
on the table okay expect that and I'm
not gonna add more all right okay I'm
ready so when I was 9 years old every
day for a summer I was brutally molested
by a guy with Down syndrome I'm gonna
let it slide that was pretty good not
smile that was really good yeah that was
really good and I'll tell you why every
day is because he okay so I lived in
Minnesota people don't know and you did
yeah for eight year that's land of the
long giant yeah I know I used to fitted
I know Minnesota I lived and there was a
you know during the summers there was
like a feel but in the winter it's like
an ice skating rink and there's a Shack
in this field so there's a Zamboni you
know what a Zamboni is right it cleans
the ice yeah right hockey so during the
summer there was like a pretty big Shack
and there was a guy with Down syndrome
that was that lived in there's a man a
grown man I wasn't mad okay and he had
candy on these rafters and he would lure
kids in with the candy Wow and he
wouldn't like you couldn't that suck as
a dick or anything like that but he was
like he would show his penis right and
then like squeeze her out it was like
weird you know but like I didn't give a
about I just wanted a candy we kind
of chanted we target like the one of the
dipping ones dippin dot all of those all
right yeah so every day and this is like
this is connected to my addiction I'm
willing to do anything to get what I
want that's interesting right so even as
a kid it's like I want the candy all
right if this guy's gonna ever this if
this guy's dick it's bad for me because
a guy with Down syndrome penis is
different was it yeah look down I don't
really remember but it was it was just
like it did I don't know man is that why
they call them down sit ideas who want
you to look at my the South don't play
innocent
don't play innocent I was a plan words
I'm for real curious I don't want a soul
there are people who have children who
are down there let's not let's not you
don't know we're not making fun oh we're
now
we're not making fun yeah attention like
that but I'm not a talker it's not a
doctor or a scientist but no it doesn't
go down so you did that for the dippin
dot right I'm not giving dogs how did
you you threw in dippin dipstick we're
all throwing things in here yeah yeah
and so he was like if you want that suck
this he didn't say yes a talk like that
but don't paraphrase it yeah well that's
what happened in the nutshell right so
then check this out so then that
happened and then when I was 12 I
started my parents have my dad is
alcoholic and you guys to have this
refrigerator in the garage and my
mommy's just stalking with liquor and so
I suggest every night we'd go into the
garage and just get 12 even before
school that's how more often started
right and then really yeah so then when
I was 17 this actually happened that was
Eddie I was at a recovery center called
Ocean View Recovery Center it was in
Oceanside California and they have this
thing called knees to knees so it's
basically what you do is you sit in
front of your parent and you touch knees
on two chairs but then all the other
kids is family they're around in a
circle around you it's so embarrassing
I'm embarrassed right my brother was
there I was 14 at time my mom was there
my dad your brother can't wait to make
fun of you
what no he does so check this out so I'm
used to these with my dad and I go yeah
when I was nine I was molested by a guy
with Down syndrome and then you can hear
his paws in the room and this is what my
dad did he laugh and then it
made my brother laugh like my brothers
like tears coming down my brother and
then my mom start laughing and then I
start laughing and they think that we're
just crazy yeah but sometimes
your Brett your dad probably didn't know
what to do
he's out of him what he did what you did
earlier yeah well it's right it's such a
curveball it's such a mindfuck yeah yeah
you don't know what to do what is right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
Oh business